I think the most memorable release that
I was ever present at is when we put
five elephants in two brand-new 4-acre
corral the elephants move forward by a
few feet all tight together in the
babies underneath them and then the
babies started squealy screaming
squealing and then the mother started
trumpeting and stamping their their feet
and thumping their trunk on the ground
it's like they knew what was going on it
was amazing but their joy the joy that
they show when they are freed from
chains is it sin it's not you cannot
mistake it this is pure joy no no no
this is Sita she lit the tiger tops
elephant camp she used to live in Chains
she doesn't any longer it's easier to
change that she used to where she did
good if I don't want it on good to her
all right she used to have this cane on
her ankle almost 24/7 it's very heavy
it's harmful to her ankle detrimental to
both physically and psychologically
she's no longer chained she now lives
chained free in a chain free Corral 24/7
when I came to Asia to look at the
situation for captive held elephants the
first thing that I noticed is that
they're all living in Chains and when
they're not doing their duty which would
be taking people for rides elephant back
safaris or in walking in festivals they
are chained and many times that's 18 19
hours of every day I proposed chained
free Corral's
I propose that we take an area a wild
area and put up a solar-powered electric
fence something that's inexpensive run
by the Sun which is important because of
course in Nepal you get maybe four or
five hours of electricity every day and
so we started with one small one acre
Corral and it took off
within a year the Government of Nepal
asked me to build a corral for every one
of their 64 elephants and in about a six
month time we built 54 Corral's so we're
here in a remote location in the buffer
zone of Chitwan National Park and here's
one of our early installations of chain
free Corral it's two Corral's one acre
each and there's one elephant that lives
there Sankar Prasad he's an adult bull
in his early 50s he's a great success
because although he has very large ivory
he's never damaged the fence
it is a pulsating energy ten volt so
it's not very strong it can't kill
anyone it definitely gives you a little
zap and you you know you back off the
advantage for elephants is that they are
fair-skinned like us so when they touch
it they're touching their bare skin they
feel it they don't want to touch it
again once they must they must a paid
one know much they pay one so I'll say
that
since reprogram Kerala Yahoo oh well I
like the Killa whenever price a at Elena
bottom freedoms holding winner can you
know the delegatee Banda know my David
of the Kilgore sir look at the one on
jello - nada he goes in our body Calgary
oh geez
David you know like when you go plus
Alex for the way Daniel H what he was
cute with other ones and Sansa just
heaven Danny couldn't make you and it
with the start they even know the one
you were in 11 my handle like he writes
on it's a toaster but I hit a current
honey this was your current whichever
quite leaner than Dan Morrison you know
the control remove any no but support or
activist usually you know my current
life she's richer on you know like
reshoot images this was suffering a
barometer of Saudi current Malaga Rossio
local optimal aging so Darryl Crowe saya
telah village a virtuous person like
manga reportero byron chinchilla that
did not work
the corrals were far too small I wasn't
happy because now that left us with nine
Bulls that were not going to be chained
free
I came here not knowing what I was going
to be doing here and I honestly don't
know what the end game is ultimately I
would like to see all captive elephants
in a natural setting nobody riding on
them nobody controlling them how that's
going to manifest I can't say but I
believe it's possible